bienvenidos al vídeo de biología
esencial número 26 que trata sobre la
conducta y cómo la conducta afecta a la
selección natural
esta es una fotografía de charles darwin
pienso que aquí tendría unos 50 años de
edad en esta fotografía parece que estás
simplemente pensando cosa que hacía
mucho está en su casa en down esta es su
vereda para pensar y lo que él hacía es
que pone algunas piedras aquí en una
pila y cada vez que daba la vuelta
patada a una piedra fuera del camino
como una manera de contar el número de
veces que pasaba por su vereda para
pensar así que darwin pensaba mucho y de
hecho si lees el origen de las especies'
tiene muchos argumentos mentales pero no
habla sobre genes y no tiene nada de
matemáticas que realmente respalde sus
argumentos entonces es darwin estaba en
lo correcto pero no hizo mediciones de
la selección natural en otras palabras
en el tiempo en el que él estaba
caminando alrededor de esa vereda todo
eso de la polilla moteada de color
blanco y color obscuro estaba ocurriendo
en inglaterra
si él hubiera estado viviendo cosa que
nadie hizo pudo haber obtenido algunos
datos que respaldarán sus teorías y hoy
en día nosotros medimos la selección
natural en todos lados y no sólo hablo
de los picos de los pinzones en las
islas galápagos sino de los grupos de
sudamérica y del virus del vih lo
medimos en todos lados y lo que quiero
hacer en este vídeo es hablar de cuatro
tipos de conducta y la manera en que
afectan a la selección natural recuerda
conducta es la manera cómo actúas y
puede ser innata o aprendida innata
significa que naciste con eso y está en
tus genes aprendida significa que lo
adquiriste a lo largo de tu vida así que
un chimpancé que aprende de su madre
cómo usar una herramienta es una
conducta aprendida sin embargo el
reflejo de agarre en un bebé chimpancé
es una conducta innata entonces vamos a
ver la conducta en los organismos y cómo
afectan la selección natural en las
plantas vamos a hablar del foto tropismo
que es el crecimiento cercano o alejado
de la luz luego la foto periodicidad el
crecimiento como respuesta a la cantidad
de luz
vamos a hablar del cortejo en los
animales como ejemplo tenemos el per
golero y finalmente hablaremos como los
organismos pueden cooperar por ejemplo
insectos y flores y cómo coordinan sus
esfuerzos en la simbiosis para la
polinización entonces empecemos con el
photo tropismo en primer lugar definamos
lo que es photo tropismo es el
crecimiento en respuesta a la luz así
que si la luz está de este lado puedes
ver en esta fotografía que si la luz
está de este lado lo que pasa con la
planta es que las auc chinas se van a
mover en sentido contrario a la luz y
eso va a provocar que las células de
este lado de la planta crezcan más
rápido que las de este lado y eso dará
como resultado que el tallo se va a
curvar hacia la fuente de luz en foto
tropismo el crecimiento se da hacia la
luz y puede ser recto o puede crecer en
algún ángulo todo esto es foto tropismo
ahora cómo se aplica esto en la
selección natural bueno cuando miras un
bosque una selva tropical como esta
piensas que es muy bonito pero realmente
hay una guerra hay una guerra
desarrollándose entre todas las plantas
de este bosque
y es una guerra por la luz todas ellas
están tratando de obtener la mayor
cantidad de luz que puedan y para todos
los árboles que ves hay una cantidad de
árboles que no ves estos árboles que no
ves no consiguen suficiente luz mueren y
sus genes mueren con ellos en otras
palabras cómo es que se llega a dar el
foto tropismo bueno podría ser que las
toxinas se usaran para otros propósitos
como simplemente hacer que las plantas
crezcan pero cuando tienes un movimiento
diferencial de oxy nash entonces puede
haber un crecimiento como respuesta a la
luz así que si una planta no puede
crecer en dirección de la luz muere y
sus genes mueren también pero se trata
de adaptarse a eso todos los días que
hay de la foto periodicidad es la
respuesta a la cantidad de luz durante
el día y con eso podemos conocer el
estado del tiempo
aquí tenemos una rosa que está
floreciendo y está tratando de atraer
polinizadores pero esta planta tiene una
elección que hacer o más bien la
decisión ya está tomada y es sobre en
qué tiempo florecer a la que tomó esta
decisión fue la selección natural así
que imaginemos que tenemos muchas rosas
y algunas florecen de forma temprana a
inicios de mayo y algunas florecen en
junio y algunas florecen en julio bueno
si florecen muy temprano puede ser que
el invierno llegue más tarde y las rosas
mueran así que a pesar de que florezcan
temprano puede ser que no resistan
porque no haya insectos que las
polinizan o posiblemente la rosa muera
ahora en julio no pensamos que en julio
sea tiempo de invierno así que como
podría morir aquí bueno digamos que
florecen tarde
eso significa que soltaran las semillas
tarde y puede ser que llegue el invierno
y les haga saber que ya no hay tiempo
para soltar la semilla entonces tenemos
esta curva en forma de campana que nos
muestra el tiempo perfecto para florecer
están conociendo el fotoperíodo mediante
el uso de sus fitocromos y de esta forma
eligen cuándo
mejor tiempo para florecer y esto ha
surgido a lo largo del tiempo en qué
momento deben florecer si florecen
demasiado temprano no funciona y si lo
hacen demasiado tarde tampoco pero como
el clima está cambiando podemos observar
que hay un desplazamiento en esta curva
de campana hacia mayo muy bien vamos a
hablar del cortejo probablemente estés
familiarizado con el cortejo entre
humanos pero el cortejo en todos los
animales es muy importante y eso se debe
a la selección sexual
este es un verbo lero el per golero
construye una enramada que es algo así
como una casa este es un verbo lero
macho que literalmente construyó toda
esta enramada en australia es un ave muy
grande y alineó a todas estas hojas de
aquí y alinea estas piedras y estas
ramas y las hojas que están puestas aquí
en otras palabras este perolero hizo que
todo esto fuera atractivo para atraer
una hembra así que las hembras vuelan
alrededor buscando la mejor en ramada y
harán pareja con el macho que pueda
construir una enramada muy bonita
similar a que un hombre tuvieron collar
muy bonito y una casa hermosa y tratará
de impresionar a una mujer por qué
sucede esto bueno si eres un per golero
que puede construir esta hermosa
enramada eso significa que probablemente
tengas un cerebro que funciona
correctamente y que probablemente tu adn
está intacto y eso es un buen indicador
de tu estado físico así que las hembras
nos muestran que los personeros machos
que son capaces de construir una buena
enramada tienen mayores posibilidades de
dejar descendencia y pasar sus genes si
tienes una enramada hecha un desastre no
pasarás tus genes y éstos serán
eliminados así aplica la selección
natural en este caso es mayormente
selección sexual y finalmente vamos a
hablar de cooperación en la polinización
la cooperación es un ejemplo de lo que
se ha llamado con evolución en otras
palabras una vez que las flores
comenzaron a florecer los insectos
comenzaron a comer las flores y en un
principio eso probablemente fue una
relación parasitaria en otras palabras
los insectos trataron de alimentarse de
las flores y las
se dieron cuenta y a lo que me refiero
con que se dieron cuenta es que de hecho
muchos de los insectos que se estaban
alimentando de las plantas transfirieron
el polen de un organismo a otro y
eventualmente se da esta co evolución
donde la evolución de una flor y la
evolución de los insectos están
inexorablemente ligadas si tenemos una
disminución en la población de abejas
qué pasará con las flores probablemente
ellas tendrían que retroceder en la
evolución recurrir al viento o alguna
otra manera de distribuir su polen y
estos ciclos nos llevan a darwin
nuevamente darwin entendió la selección
natural entendió todo esto
desafortunadamente no lo estudió en
realidad no midió estas cosas pero él
estaba buscando en madagascar no creo
que haya ido a madagascar no sé si fue o
no pero estaba observando la orquídea de
darwin el nombre vino después pero lo
interesante es que había un pie de
distancia entre la parte externa de la
flor y la parte de abajo donde se
encuentra el néctar así que darwin vio
esta flor y predijo que en el futuro
encontrarían un tipo de insecto
algo que tuviera una probos y de
realmente larga y lo que encontraron fue
esta polilla esta polilla tiene una
producida que normalmente en una
mariposa o una polilla se encuentra
enrollada cuando está volando alrededor
pero la desenrollan para obtener el
néctar que está dentro a esta polilla la
llamamos santo pan morgan i predict a
hilo de predict a es por la predicción
que hizo darwin de que la propósito
tendría esa longitud así que esta es la
coevolución entre estos organismos pero
esencialmente la conducta que asumas
determina si sobrevives o mueres y esto
nos conduce a la selección natural y
eventualmente a la adaptación de los
organismos espero que esto sea útil